the cheese industry is caught in the
crossfire of US trade disputes with
other countries China is expected to
implement new tariffs today on us cheese
industry in other sections the US
Chamber of Commerce says retaliatory
tariffs against the US threatened about
a billion dollars worth of Wisconsin's
exports which include cheese Dean
Reynolds visited the Sartori cheese
Company where 12% of its business
depends on exports at the Sartori cheese
plant in Plymouth Wisconsin turning
humble curds into parmesan cheddar and
other table favorites is a thing to
behold but these days in addition to
dipping their 20 pound wheels into wine
or hand rubbing them with pepper and
unwanted ingredient is being added to
their business tariffs the president is
focused on helping protect American
workers and American industries and
create a fair playing field that's fine
says Jeff Schwager the president of
Sartori company but tariffs are the
wrong way to reach that goal I have yet
to find an example where tariffs have
worked for the long-term good of the
country that first imposes them
the president's protectionist moves have
prompted US trading partners to
retaliate with tariffs of their own on
such Wisconsin exports as cranberries
apples and harley-davidson motorcycles
American cheese is more expensive to buy
now in Mexico and Canada
Sarris two biggest foreign markets US
dairy exports totaled 5.5 billion
dollars last year including 1.3 billion
to Mexico alone if this is gonna go on
long term the customers down there will
look for an alternative product without
the tariffs on it overproduction has
already created a glut of milk on the
market driving down dairy prices and
threatening some of the 130 family farms
on which Sartori relies Stacey Limburg
has 75 cows this is a great time to be
dairy farmer no it's not we don't make a
lot of money we're not really making any
money at this point in time the Limbourg
farm produces about 5,000 pounds of milk
every day
you can't just snap your fingers and
stop that flow these are animals after
all we don't know are the companies and
eventually going to put a limit on how
much we can produce per day how much we
can ship per day that's that's a big if
Stacey voted for mr. Trump but wonders
why he made trade such a big deal do you
think he created an issue that wasn't
really an issue from your point of view
right now yes and in hindsight yes she
hopes this may just be a negotiating
ploy by the President and so does Jeff
Schwager is this a bluff you know III
don't know that it's a bluff but I sure
hope there's a strategy behind this for
CBS this morning Dean Reynolds Plymouth
Wisconsin